welcome to this video playing Jimmy
floof Jimmy schlumpf International
Master Louis Schreuder and I don't know
this guy actually um what okay let me
let me not screw this up what what am I
allowed to play I think maybe a modern
defense yeah modern defense should be
okay I'm not allowed to play the Kings
Indian but the modern should be sorry
should be fine hmm okay yeah so maybe I
can funny move over there interesting
move water he keeps c4 open yet so if i
play something like East 6 a-6 on
anything funky like that it's less you
form um yes so here normally goes like
this antam you know
i think i recently i somehow remember
that i lost the game they're quite badly
when I somehow him when I somehow got
into a really bad Kings Indian type of
structure what is this fact if I take a
night before isn't this just good he
cannot keep the bishop now I mean you
should move i'm taking before I guess
what does he have something something
tactical that I don't see nope so he
gives me this Bishop and if people give
me bishops I'm going to take it going to
take them usually I came I'm trying to
set it up with d5 okay played d5 himself
interesting think taking is probably
right opening up for the bishop am
they have Bishop f5 now which is kind of
the obvious move but it's probably also
correct activating this thing on Queen
d2 after pushing away King h7 is too
slow and they have 94 now so here we go
take stakes and I'm threatening Bishop
f3 Queen f6 I guess playing quickly here
but it looks kind of normal everything
and here yeah d5 hangs and I'm taking it
I think no reason not to it's a big big
sent upon Jeff
so he tries to treat everything down
here okay check
Queenie for then m3 mmm says some way
yeah 3 it's actually quite weakening but
still helps him a little bit so what is
he doing actually he wants to check here
probably it's there a good setup here
for me maybe here Bishop's is 625 not
entirely sure taking it Queen c3 is just
winning so yeah yeah it's not so clear
modem but what's the best set of us I
think putting the Queen on d5 should be
good
yeah not much the same he's sitting
there with his pawn down and doesn't
move yeah 25 I don't really see a
clear-cut way after that my king is a
bit weak so I have to be concerned
they're a little bit so anything better
no let's put it here that was the idea
and now this this was my idea activating
the bishop possibly coming there come
the good thing is that all kinds of
trades here are good and almost winning
for black like night against bishop okay
at the moment is pinned he cannot take
any way but this is some okay let's do
this glad to enter and then Queenie five
next for Bishop g3 maybe special be 5mm
screen is not having many squares to
cannot take
maybe
wonder if coming f5 is playable fam yeah
it might be playable for him if I take
it h6 is hanging and the d6 porn is
quite vulnerable to Bishop c7's almost
like that surprisingly tricky
and be Queen five every community five I
can take be five then okay let's let's
grab that King here but I don't know
this is this doesn't look look great in
terms of winning chances Bishop seaside
whining so here for a self-penned maybe
that looks better than d55 ok that send
it to this chap that's disappointing
that's really disappointing this this
development here I can still have the
bishop so it's not like completely
simple
I need texting them no Jeff um some
scrap space and no come over ya have to
have to watch out for the time Jeff Jeff
Jeff Joe I totally screwed that up after
this whole trip unbelievable really how
to believe
grah offered gras offered game drown I'm
actually winning with age for that I'm
just winning with age for now Chad that
was that was tricky a little bit tricky
maybe I had the wrong idea initially
there this is ok but maybe here I have
to I have to play different layer we
should be 5 p.m. but i wasn't sure
already yeah specially five is actually
quite good you know what I did not
really think about as thought if he
takes ok I have that one the chat is
very simple no I thought check check I
go somewhere and I thought he will take
and I did not really see I can take with
the pawn this is quite simple now the
queen is sorry had to roll arrow there
but I'm protecting all my pawns I was
thinking after this I'm losing be seven
and I'll k-k-kiss to can't take be too
yeah so but this is this is nothing
checks too much better but not anymore
here after this check check yeah this is
the sir should probably end in a draw
yeah i blundered into this night be
seven he can claim this is a draw
that's a draw but then hear ya we agree
to a draw but he I can win with age from
yeah that was a bad result there but uhm
Jung still even with those kind of
strange opening get get decent positions
got a very nice position that time okay
well thanks for watching